well presidency is set to secure a
historic third term as leader of the
world's most populous nation but as
Patrick Fox reports mounting challenges
at home and abroad are raising questions
about a political system dominated by
one man
deep in rural shansi Province lies the
village of liangyahur
it's where China's leaders spent seven
years as a teenager living in caves
carved out of the hills under Mazi
Dong's campaign to re-educate Urban
youths in one of them several posters of
modern China's Founding Father Xi
Jinping endured hard labor during his
time here he's said to have struggled
with the squalor of Rural Life and once
escaped to Beijing only to be arrested
and sent back and yet he embraced the
Communist party and Mao he found a role
model he's the first leader since the
death of Mao in 1976 to acknowledge the
legacy of Mao without reservation it
follows Mao in the way he governs the
party The Cult of Personality it's very
Mouse style now as the CCP nears its
critical once every five years Congress
Xi Jinping is expected to cement his
status as China's most powerful leader
since Mao having scrapped presidential
term limits in 2018 he's all but
guaranteed to secure a third term at the
helm during a decade in office he's
developed a strong Cult of his own
medical student warning Shah is a party
faithful confident in the direction she
is taking the country towards
history has chosen him the people have
chosen him he's also chosen us it goes
both ways it's only because he's
impacted the country positively that we
continue to choose him but China is also
facing increasing challenges under shi's
leadership strict over lockdowns across
the country have hobbled the economy and
crippled Global Supply chains embedded
property developers struggling to
complete projects have also dented
confidence in a key sector that makes up
about a fifth of GDP
their Affairs also she could further
press beijing's claims over Taiwan and
step up military intimidation over the
South ruled Island it really depends on
domestic situation if the economic
situation is really going down laying
um he will actually face a lot of
resistance uh domestically then probably
he will think about Taiwan issue
political observers expect she will stay
on beyond the third term and that he may
be plotting as mounted to rule for life
but Power preservation could
increasingly Trump policy and plunge
China into a period of uncertainty and
instability
Patrick Frank Al Jazeera Beijing
well let's bring in David Martin he's a
political Economist and founder of man
China investment management and he joins
us now from Beijing good to have you
with us first of all why does she say
that this is a critical moment for China
well he's facing a number of forces that
he didn't anticipate
um four or five years ago which is first
the zero covert policy and the Chinese
economy has really slowed and in some
places stalled so he's stuck between a
problem with releasing zero covert and
there still remain something like 52
million people over 60 in the
countryside and vaccinated despite the
fact that Chinese cities the vaccination
rates about 90 percent so we didn't go
hundreds of thousands will die if he
holds on to it the economy will
to even lose more momentum and there'll
be more businesses going bankrupt so
it's a very difficult situation and no
one's really sure what choices he'll
make well he has said hasn't he that
he's going to stay the course with zero
covert what's been the reaction to that
many people hope that he would be
announcing today that there'd be a
change in policy
um I think the fact that he says he will
stay the course doesn't mean that the
policy won't loosen and there are a
number of things they can do they can
reduce the quarantine days people can
quarantine at home just today one of my
colleagues schools has been closed and
some families have been taken to a
quarantine facility in the mountains you
know it's not Draconian but it's
extremely disruptive they perhaps could
have quarantined at home so those
flexibilities are things which I don't
think they will announce as a major step
but they will begin to allow to loosen
they must because if we don't do
something by March economy is in real
trouble we know that she is going to be
staying in power for at least another
five years but what changes in the power
structure should we be looking out for
over the next six days
I don't think we'll see any changes in
the past structure the next six days is
to confirm confirm what's taken place
over the last 18 to 24 months all the
horse training handling cajoling and the
discussions that have meant as one raft
of leaders retire and revolve from one
post to another there's a whole new
group of people coming in the core will
be it will be loyal to she many will be
there just on Merit and not particularly
connected to the center and people
forget that this is the period of
concluding economic reform and renewal
every five years
so I think it matters more what the next
two years look like
we'll see whether she begins to plan for
succession and I'm not one of these
people who believes that he's there for
life I think he's there because the
party sale Expedia for him to be there
and the fact that he is generally
popular more popular than his last two
predecessors how popular he is amongst
people and and whether people across
China are happy to see him taking on
this third term
I think many senior officials are not
because it blocks their own advancement
I think intellectuals are not because in
their analysis of China they perhaps
take them more complex view but I travel
all the time around China
the rural areas Shanghai
um intermediate cities and the general
view is that the anti-corruption
campaign has brought a stability to
China that in the modern era at
hessington Droid and by and large the
economy the disciplines around banking
list of General regulations and business
they've made a much more stable economy
now this has been stretched by zero
covered policies there's no question but
if in the next few months that can be an
alteration of their stringent terms I
think we're still dealing with a party
that knows they have someone who is
immensely popular and so he will remain
in power but the party structure won't
let him rule for life he's not bigger
than the party no one is bigger than the
party
David Mann great to speak to you thanks
for taking the time to join us there
from Beijing